[Music]
my name is Francis Nagar moon tonight I
am a professor at Columbia University in
the partner of English and comparative
literature and the project that I've
been developing is called Bologna cambio
which is supported by the Center for the
Study of social difference and in emerge
from a working group called unpayable
debt that looked at the rise of debt
regimes all over the world but we put a
particular emphasis on Puerto Rico for
our research and the name of our group
comes directly from a speech that the
Governor of Puerto Rico game when he
announced to the island that the
government had accumulated such an
enormous amount of debt that he called
it on payable if you combine all debt
that the government has it tops 120
billion the project I would describe it
as a art storytelling and just economy
project to launch an island-wide
conversation about what do we value as a
society introducing a tool a community
currency that could be used for
communities that are marginalized or
have little access to the formal economy
to organize their resources and talents
inside their communities through
exchange of a community currency we also
wanted the currency to tell stories of
the past that connected to the present
so we picked figures and places that
allowed us to talk of burning issues now
like public education public health or
access to health we wanted to talk about
racial and gender equity I think the
most popular bill was 21 Roberto
Clemente who was a baseball player and
also was known for his humanitarian work
so the way work was we we got an ATM we
added a computer to the ATM so it could
collect the stories and in exchange of
the stories we would give the
dispenser or money dispenser we got a
number of small businesses about 40
small businesses to accept these bills
so the idea was that we would
demonstrate and through a participatory
process what could an exchange economy
not based on profit or debt for
accumulation look like and feel like we
had a very interdisciplinary group all
of us trying to understand how do we get
to this point and I think also how can
research our journalism these various
areas that we were working on can have
an impact in addressing the situation
and our project is not about how Puerto
Rico is going to pay what we see is the
crisis is offering an opportunity for
people to rethink politics to rethink
what the economy should be about Mabel -
mucho el proyecto por que mesas until up
in the other Sarala home in 8k Valley
neutropenia balli
[Music]